yeah but all that all this is done is
just heightens my fear of like deep
water and thalassophobia basically yeah
and I'm glad that uh I'm not alone in
that I'm glad so many people fear the
ocean like I do that's why I don't think
I can like I think after this I've
always like I've been on the cusp of the
time with the ocean you're like I'm done
I'm done with the ocean I was like maybe
scuba diving would be cool I want a
scuba dive yeah and then you just hear
like I think the internet has just
ruined me because I've known of like I
see so many horror stories of like
difference yeah and like the wildest
thing is just that you know this idea of
being trapped underwater and having to
like surface slowly at a time no matter
what unless you get decompression
sickness and I'm like nope nope I am
never going that deep I will draw the
line at snorkeling I this this is as far
as I will go if I can see if I can't see
the bottom I am not going there baby I
love how they call it decompression
sickness but it's like hey you'll just
explode yeah yeah it's kind of sick it's
very sick yeah hey gospel just like just
uh but your your blood would just start
bubbling you know did you ever do you
ever see that uh that uh it was like a
ship and it was like an oil ship or
something and there was some boats
around it and they were trying to they
were trying to do something and there's
a giant [__] storm and the ship
overturned uh and sank to the bottom but
there was an air pocket in the ship
where this dude was just I I've seen
this one yeah and but he was like on the
ocean floor yeah like and he obviously
didn't have any gear or anything so they
had to like this guy who had literally
survived in the cold ass water on the
bottom of the ocean which is chilling in
this room and they sent some divers I
don't know I wasn't like crazy but they
sent some divers to double check that
there's no one else alive because this
sometimes happens and it overturns yeah
yeah all the air gets trapped and this
is video on YouTube of the diver going
into the ship and he's just searching
and this guy is above the water
otherwise he'd freeze and die he's like
he's on something
and then the diver a hand just grabs the
diver and it's this dude who'd been
living there for like three or four days
jeez no no food or anything just like
freezing in this room and they managed
to save him I think yeah it's insane
also I can't imagine being the diver at
that point because that I would [__]
myself I I would literally [__] myself
now I would like fear [__] in that
moment that would have been the biggest
jump scare of my entire yeah it might
just go to a shipwreck at the bottom of
the ocean and then you feel something
grabbed you holy [__] that is the thing
of like horror stories like watching
watching these divers camera you can't
see anything yeah they only see dust and
they just listen to a guy on comms
directly through the blueprints it's
like this is [__] this is so [__]
like the fact that you have to navigate
this and this is someone's job and
people aren't like freaking out 24 7.
well at least they took a diver down
instead of a sob right
yeah well I promise if you do a sub down
you kind of get [__] out yeah yeah
so it's crazy and they have been there
to like base actually teach this guy how
to use the mask and decompress and go up
the fact that he survived is insane yeah
I think I'm pretty sure he survived yeah
it's kind of [__] [__] now have you
guys ever been on any cruises or
anything like that oh that's uh that's
[__] no [__] no no maybe when I'm like
70 or 80. no no it just seems like not
now the worst thing ever yeah I think
it'd be nice if you're like at a retired
state where you're just like oh I've got
nothing to do no time I'm not gonna I'm
not talking about like you know [__]
weeks-long cruises like that would just
be torturous like maybe like a few days
at most yeah no then I'd be like you
know I can just chill on like a nice
boat deck for a few days go in the pool
maybe bathe in the sun you know I'm I'm
in a retired state right now I've got
nothing to worry about kind of thing
that would be nice but like those like
week-long cruises
bro I think I would go insane yeah
because you're you've you're literally
just obviously trapped on the boat yeah
with just like I don't know it's no
different to being like trapped in a
building for like two weeks you know
also I don't think I could ever be fully
comfortable just being on like the ocean
that long I don't know is it is that a
weird mental thing because I'm like
playing you're on like a skyscraper on
the ocean yeah yeah like barely like
it's so those things are huge yeah
because like five times the size of the
Titanic yeah I'm like plain that's fine
I'm in the air that makes more sense to
me than being like on the water for
someone what are you afraid of of the
ship sinking yeah actually yeah at least
with a plane crash it's like a quick
death you know
I just I'm just saying I'm just saying I
mean not all the time
I mean there's been plane crashes where
people survive yeah I mean I'm sure
there's been plane crashes and probably
died agonizingly yeah that too there's
like no difference okay but like I feel
I feel like you know you're not supposed
to skydive yeah I do want to skydive
actually
it's like jumping out jumping out of a
plane okay I'm fine with that yeah
getting in a huge body of water no get
get that [__] get that [__] away no
because like there's like so many things
like
I do like watching
watching uh videos of Just massive waves
hitting oil rigs [__] crazy oh yeah
because you just realized the amount of
energy that's just like encapsulated a
cruise ship isn't going to go through
that [__] they'll be like we might
expect
that's what they said about the Titanic
Joey Unsinkable yeah
[__] you're right what I'm running is
that just you should just stay off the
ocean gone yeah I just should just stay
off the ocean really ironic you it's the
fact that you used to live near a body
of water like your whole life okay I
love beaches I just hate the ocean
I love seeing the ocean the ocean is
there to be seen or not be trodden fair
enough yeah I mean have you heard about
like rogue waves and [__] like that yeah
yeah I've seen that yeah what's that
like I I okay as much as I feel the
ocean I do genuinely find it fascinating
to like read about this is there's a
concept that waves should only be as big
as they you know like they recorded it
um but there's been like accounts and
they've recorded these anomaly waves
that are like giggle waves right like
one giant not not a tsunami not caused
by tsunamis
these giant [__] waves that are like
20 times or ten times the height of the
what the wave should be yeah right like
like like these are like life-ending
waves yeah and I don't think there is a
scientific explanation for them or a pro
a proper scientific explanation for them
yeah right but yeah to to go on what
Connor said like it was it was like
calculated years ago this is the highest
height a wave can possibly be be by
science you know that's that's what
scientists said and then you know you
had these accounts of like Sailors who
have just been like I've encountered a
wave like twice or three times as big
and people people just thought you're
you're a [__] liar you're a liar
until modern technology came about and
people started documenting them
especially in offshore oil rigs and
sometimes there are waves that you know
100 meters tall yeah yeah that's that
have not been able to be explained about
why these waves can exist and these are
called rogue waves and I find them
scared of the ocean I am scared of the
ocean man I find I find it fascinating
though that's cool it's super
interesting yeah it's it's it's super
interesting about those like giant
squids and [__] too oh oh yeah yeah
those are [__] cool though yo don't
tell Japan about that
how big you say everyone else is like
stay away from the [__] giant it's
dangerous trans like all right boys
[Laughter]
yo we're feeding the family and the
entire town of this let's go yeah
because isn't it like they've only
before they actually got footage of the
giant squid I think it's like the only
evidence that they had that this thing
might exist is because they've seen
whales be beached up with these like
huge [__] marks on them after a fight
and they figured out that it's like
metal giant cephalopod or something yeah
yeah
and then they finally got footage of it
like a few years ago and it's like yeah
it just looks like straight out of
[__] Pirates of the Caribbean it's
like a terrifying yeah no [__] yourself
scary [__] sperm whales right yeah
like who you know you've said giant
squids and I think sperm whales like
generally hunt giant squids yeah like
apparently like their click is like so
loud that if they clicked when you were
next to it you could literally like
vibrate you to death yeah or at least at
the very least burst your eardrums yeah
and I see you I see clips of divers
close to sperm whales getting footage
and I'm like you are taking one big
[__] risk I'm sure that near like
there was divers near they'd
accidentally seen like a submarine and
yeah uh they obviously didn't realize
and they posted it but like if the
submarine like pinged sonar yeah like
completely like probably killed them
yeah I think it would immediately burst
like a lot of that like rupture a lot of
their organs because it's so powerful
this is
terrifying and I'm like why why are you
taking that risk what well it's gone
Well's gonna sneeze what if what what if
what if they haven't itched somewhere
like that what if there's
like you know what if what if a whale
was just like farts
from the Shockwave
it's like some anime [__] like a like a
nen blast
[__] rupture start coughing up blood
you're like
it's the most powerful fight in the
universe